on home turf for what could be the most
consequential prosecution in U.S history
America's 45th president but the first
to face something like this
will a slow drive down this road for
Donald Trump but I have to say there are
not very many supporters here he will
surely be hoping that his base swells a
little more than this
the support that was here conservatives
from across the Spectrum were angry
determined and representing so many more
across the country
he's you know being pecked on really all
the other presidents have done the same
thing he's doing I think the allegations
against Joe Biden and his family are
significantly more serious than the ones
against Donald Trump it breaks my heart
to think that we are on a way to
becoming a Banana Republic here
the seriousness of the charges are not
their focus because this is the court of
public opinion they believe it is a hit
job by Biden to remove his political
rival outside the courthouse itself the
stage is set to record this spectacle
it's unprecedented it's double
unprecedented because he's also indicted
in New York John sale has the context of
History he remembers Watergate better
than most because he was a special
prosecutor against President Nixon well
reading the indictment is shocking I
mean it is incredible amount of detail
uh it talks about recklessly
storing National Security information
talking about it to people who don't
have clearance and it's portrays former
president Trump as a great threat to One
National Defense Mr sale also
represented Donald Trump's associate
Rudy Giuliani Trump wanted him to for a
previous case but Mr sale turned him
down how do you counter The View that we
hear everywhere among Trump supporters
what about ISM they what about President
Biden and his
document Scandal what about Hillary
Clinton her emails what about Mike Pence
how do you counter that the big
difference is cooperation and when
President Trump was served as subpoena
last spring if he had told his lawyer
look
I want to turn over everything I want to
comply with the subpoena dual diligent
search everything we have turn it over
to the grand jury you and I wouldn't be
here today yet so many believe this is a
Witch Hunt where does that leave
American Justice an American society
well that's that's the right question
the American Juris judicial system is on
trial also and the whole world is
watching it him up baby this President
without precedent will be in court this
afternoon Mark Stone Sky News in Miami